In this lesson,
we'll use the same pattern to add
cards from movies from a database.
Cards can be created to display
any type of data you want.
After all, they're just views.
For example, to display a movie card,
you could create a view with an image
view for art work, and
a text view for the title.
Here, we'll actually
use an image card view,
which is provided by
the Leanback library.
First, let's take a quick look at
what our movies database looks like.
I'm back inside the LoadRows method now,
and
I'm going to uncomment the line
that loads our dummy database.
By the way, our dummies database is
actually going to pull images over
the web, so you'll need an internet
connection from here on out.
Let's check out the Movie class.
Basically a Movie is a simple container
class with a title and a description,
and a couple of images
that we'll get to later.
The setup movies method creates
five movies with this data.
Now we'll create cards to display these.
Back inside the low rows method,
I'm going to undo
the comments I did earlier.
And by the way, the UI that we're
going to create will contain
rows of five videos,
organized randomly and repeated.
First, we'll create a presenter that we
can use to create views for our movies.
Let's take a look inside this class.
Scrolling down a bit, as before
there's two methods we care about,
onCreateViewHolder and onBindViewHolder.
This time instead of a text view,
onCreateViewHolder creates
a view using a ImageCardView.
This is a class provided by Leanback and
it's a card with a picture and
some text.
Whereas, previously we passed
a string to our presenter,
here we pass a movie object.
We cast the parameter to
the appropriate type, and
this time,
we set multiple fields on the view.
In this loop, we create a rows of cards.
In a real app, these would be
organized in some sensible way.
Here, we just randomly create
rows of five cards and
assign them a category name.
As before, we need to create an object
adapter that will hold the presenter
that's used to create views for movies,
as well as the movies themselves.
Here's where we add movies
from our database to it.
And now we create the header item that
will be used for the category name.
Then we wrap the header and
our list of five movies into a list row.
And we add that list row to the object
adaptor we previously created,
that has our list row presenter.
Run your project at this point and
see what you get.
Not.